men or women oh women so then wouldn't
you say it's women's fault for giving
out sex for free so let's not get this
confused I am a hundred percent that
women are not being held accountable at
all right but it we there's a balancing
factor and why can that coexist yes we
aren't holding each other accountable or
things like that but there's still a
standard of a men allowing that that we
aren't hold accountable but that's the
only thing that I'm saying but that's
the only thing what we've already proven
is that it's not the majority of men it
is a five to ten percent that women are
choosing to give their bodies to and lay
down with do you know there are between
18 and 30 there are I I think the
numbers three times the number of men
who are virgins then there are girl than
women who are virgins women can run
through body count and run through I
mean I did a a video where I talked
about how I read women's body counts
like women
anonymously business women these are not
women there were strippers and for the
street they actually gave their body
count there was a 29 year old woman that
had 150 plus and she said I wish it was
higher oh my God and even women who had
low body count low numbers of men they
said it should be higher they actually
feel embarrassed like I should be living
little and and I used to feel there was
there's no shame about it if you ask the
same men unless they are certain looks
they have a certain amount of looks or
money and Status they can't get the
average woman if if all of us women went
outside right now and was just like
listen
come back to the crib let's go to the
car let's go to the alley I'm gonna bust
it down for you I'm gonna give it to you
we can rack up the whole city we can
rack up all of London and one night but
a man if they can go outside even if
they look good even after status they
still have a level of work they they may
be on a good night could maybe get two
if they are just really really really
good women have sex with who they want
men have sex
of them changes to the outcome of their
relationships in the future I mean I'm
not going to say that it has no impact
but which one is significantly more if a
man sleeps with a hundred a hundred
women can he settle down I would argue
still yeah but what if a woman sleeps
with a hundred man she men she can't
women men care about quantity women care
about quality of the women so if I see
I'm like that's your ex-girlfriend
that's who you slept with uh like if
she's like a bus down or I know she's a
known hoe or the dude just slept with
prostitutes we would be upset as women a
man will care about the number of men
that she has slept with we care about
the quality because we're almost like
that's why that's why if a man has a
other women around him who look good
other women around him that look good or
his girlfriend looks good he's like
pre-qualified we're just like oh he's
got a baddie it in US it incites like
he's pre-qualified whereas we care about
if we say a good looking guy with like a
girl that looks terrible like he's
probably broke he's probably this I
wouldn't want him a man doesn't care
about that all he gives was quantity
what were you gonna say but to the point
right it's 80 of women who are out here
doing these things it's five to ten
percent of men who are sleeping with
them but if they are running through the
80 percent of women and now they are
disqualifying them from being good good
wives so if first needs that's the
choice
hold them accountable so women are
opening their legs you just said that
women control sex how would the 80 of
men just running through these women
ability needs to start with women and
locking that down and not doing that
right so then the five to ten percent of
men who are running have no place to go
right that is
all the accountability because all the
women are sleeping with that five to ten
percent so we need to women need the
accountability the five to ten percent
it like like so like no I'm sorry the
majority of men no that's not women if
80 of women are choosing these five to
ten percent ma'am you have not you
sweetheart I'm just talking in general I
know when I say ma'am I'm just talking
so I'm just saying like how are we going
to blame men when it's five to ten
percent that's getting 80 percent of the
women out here it's us women if five
percent five to ten percent of women
were choosing to sleep with those five
to ten percent men let them go off and
do their thing but we have women in Mass
the majority of women that are given
themselves to these low quality tyrones
pookies and ray rays that don't really
that don't care when those good men that
are right around you but you don't want
him because he's corny and only one
influences the outcome of your
relationship like the the man sleeping
with multiple women it's not going to
influence the outcome of his
relationship but it sure as hell is
going to influence the outcome of hers
for her future husband
so that makes it okay though but we live
in a time where we can watch some of
these Tick Tock videos with these Street
interviews and the guys are asking girls
about what have you done what's what's
what have you got to confess and these
girls are saying they've been ran
through they've had five guys in one
night and we've now got to the point
yeah we've got to the apartment no you
do not believe that sex outside of
marriage is wrong
so yes but yeah but do you still partake
yes right so in modern culture it's it's
relevant right then you're blaming
culture I'm not blaming culture that's
just what that's the reality right now
because yeah right but that's your as an
individual you have individual
accountability I don't care what culture
is doing I make a choice with my box
culture is not going to give me STD
culture is not gonna give make me I'm
culture's not going to take care of when
I have a um you know I'm an unwed mother
culture is not going to take care of
those things I am responsible for my
body my my who I give my body to I have
soul ties to if you choose to spread
your legs open in these streets Society
did not make you do that you made the
choice to lay down with all of those men
and you can and putting it on and then
they take accountability you chose to
bust it open for that F boy or or that
Pookie that is your choice
however I'll say this go off when your
Society tells you that something is okay
so what we've seen within the next we've
been the past 10 years is a spike in
people that are calling themselves
non-binary and trans right we've seen a
spike in it why because the society has
said it's okay to be that way there's no
choice right it is that it is their
choice but I'm saying we have to
understand that when society says
something is okay it has an impact on
individuals like this is the reality
because there's a reason why you don't
allow your children to watch certain
things on TV right now
hang on there's a reason why you don't
allow your children to watch certain
things on TV there's a reason why you
don't allow your children to go around
certain people why because as much as
you could teach your child and say don't
do this that's wrong right your child
can still be influenced right by a
certain people your choice even as a
child it's your choice who you surround
yourself with like I remember being like
a kid and thinking these girls were mad
and thinking these girls were crazy and
it's like even even as a child you have
some accountability for the the friends
you choose to surround yourself with but
what what where does accountability come
from it comes from the influences it
comes from our society and all I'm
saying is we can't discredit no no
accountability
I don't agree accountability comes from
yourself and the ability to take where's
that shape from them
every woman every woman that has laid
down with the five to ten percent man
there is another woman who was raised in
some of the circumstances or worse that
made a different decision so that's
where your accountability is be because
you can have all the excuses Society
everybody all of this but there is
another person out there that made a
difference and a better choice just
because you were born in that then you
have to say why did they make a better
choice and I chose to do this so if one
person in the world made a better choice
than you then you have to say Society
didn't influence them Society didn't do
this why am why am I so weak why am I so
unaccountable that I want to blame
everyone else if one person has made a
better choice than you then you need to
rise to the cream of the crop but so
many of us are at the bottom we want to
be like everybody else we want to be
regular we want to be at we want to be
below average and we don't strive for
excellence in anything that we do
creates Society I think we're missing
something the one percent of men do who
know I'm saying like who passes on
culture in a family exactly and then
yeah one thing that that's missing it is
nothing about the individual and we're
talking about Society we have completely
neglected the home and the family
because I would argue that if an older
woman had told this younger lady or any
younger lady that this is how boys see
you if you do that you would act
differently if someone had told you that
I think men do a much better job of
checking each other because men see
themselves in younger men women see
themselves as younger women so a man
bars
you better teach
er
a man looks at his life in phases he
knew he was a boy he knew he was a young
man he knew he was you know a bachelor
and then he's like I'm ready to set it
down a woman doesn't do that a woman
still thinks even though I'm 40 or 50 or
whatever I can still twerk like a little
girl I can still wear revealing clothing
I think there's some Sierra
I would say what men build societies
women pass on the culture typically yes
they do and so by that by that logic if
the culture's bad whose fault is it
the women and the who's breaking up
homes men are away the whole word right
there so and and if if we're if we're
growing up in a family that doesn't in a
society that doesn't value family whose
fault is it no I think that's women I
agree they're breaking up the home we
actually done something on that and I
actually said uh if the woman's not
right because she's the first teacher of
children right so if the woman's not
right the society is not going to be
right because if you're the first
teacher of the children as women you
spend most of the time with the children
so if you are the one that is constantly
and consistently around the children
then the child's not going to be right
and the Childs are the ones that go out
into society
I think I actually heard you said po
before that's the thing in single mother
homes that's when kids do bad you always
deemed a father figure in the home to be
able to coach and teach the child how to
be disciplined and accountable in life
there are some though in single months
we have these outliers like LeBron James
single mother
um you know family and even his wife
Savannah James that's why I brought her
her up if you saw her a picture of
Sierra and you put a picture of of
Savannah James at the Oscars
Savannah James Every Woman across the
board like people are talking about
that's my wedding dress like she's
inspired me she is she is gold she is it
she was a single mother very young she
was raised by a single mother LeBron
James so even even if you raise a single
mother poverty all your circumstances
look at people who made different
choices if they made other choices you
have no excuse if somebody else came out
of your sisters and let's be honest
right now ladies and gentlemen
everything we're talking about right now
is very lightweight and weak if we look
at history and what people have gone
through in real struggle and what we
call you know hardship and it's not my
my choice look I mean you look at the
society as a whole throughout you know
all of Europe Africa and everywhere we
are living in a time of of absolute
privilege and so when we when we in the
accountability that they had to take
that it is just even this conversation
is is is spoiled and it is privileged
and it is very we don't know hard work
we don't know what it's like to really
struggle so we can even have the luxury
of having these conversations like this
and and and and it's it's it was life
and death for a woman to lose her
virginity to the streets okay it was
life and death it means you would be a
destitute you were actually sent to the
brothels if you aged out you know
because you did not marry at a certain
age you were sent to work in the in the
Brothel House changed right and so it
now it's only fans and so and and
Instagram so what we're seeing is even
these conversations we really as a
society now don't know accountability
and I mean if we really want to go there
but overall I would say absolutely the
onus is on the women to pass down the
culture teach the young women our young
women are out of pocket struggling
because the older women are for the
streets many of them you have women who
are in their 40s still being IG models
getting bust down down and flew out flew
flewed out is what they call it and just
doing the most and looking like
strippers what we call even cute outfits
today sexy this is what you know I I
don't know what I'm gonna say the word
but like women of uh uh ladies of the
night would wear in old times and
there's no accountability you're 45
years old man and you're dressing like
your daughter doing Tick Tock and trying
to show how thick you are because you
want that same 30 year old man because
as your daughter can get you can get the
same man he'll be in let's say he's 33
you're 40 your daughter's 20. he's 30.
you're trying to get that man because
you're so lost and so consumed into
yourself you have nothing to teach but
old box but I think that's the reason
why men are supposed to be the ones
leading Society exactly right and I
think that's the reason why
um because we like I said discussed
earlier on women are not going to give
younger women the keys to the game it's
just not going to do it it's competition
they're not going to do it sitting
around asking and expecting them to do
it you'll be waiting a long time for
them to do that right so it's for
mentally Society so when you talk about
Society about Society has been
fragmented and it's been broken so now
men can be women and women can be men
and the whole thing's topsy-turvy and
upside down and so the reason for
society being this way is because men
aren't allowed to lead men like TMR men
like myself we get called misogynistic
do you know what I mean when we try to
lead we get called all types of Earth
doesn't say so if if you're Dusty then
say so if you're if you're gay then say
so we get shamed for trying to be
leaders do you get what I'm saying so
the society going back to who leads
Society
um I would say there's a part of like I
said those one percent of men
whoever they are those one percent the
same people that put Andrew Tate in jail
those men are the ones that are trying
to
um cultivate society and show people
that if you step out of line like an
entry Tate then they'll try and put you
back in check modern women hate
accountability so much that they cheered
when Kevin Samuels passed away
accountability by and large but here's
the thing is that
because they are the product of the
society they are raised in and a lot of
them are just Hive Minds
that I can't really be mad at them at
the end of the day because if you've
been lied to consistently throughout
your life or fed the propaganda
that sells a product to you
and you believe that because it benefits
you they cannot really be mad at you
that you fed into the propaganda well
there's examples all throughout history
where propaganda has led to some of the
uh the most major calamities throughout
our history and our civilization because
people just believed in something
unwittingly and unknowingly without
questioning it but do you guys think
that the phrase is actually go ahead and
write oh no I was just gonna say and to
your point MTR I think what Kevin
Samuels did was hold up a mirror and we
had a decision to make yes we had been
lied to yes some of us had those modern
Tendencies but it was basically a Line
in the Sand and then you can say okay am
I going to stick my head back in the
sand la la and say I don't want to hear
that anymore and you should go away bad
man or am I going to say you know what
am I really fit feminine and friendly
right and those same women who cheered
his death you still lonely you still
need to buy a dog and die alone and you
still and you still aren't succeeding
but you've listened I I mean Kevin was a
personal friend of mine he was a
personal friend of him of MTR here and
like we knew he loved he was trying to
help he was the stern father you never
had see I had a father my father sounds
like Kevin to this day and holds me
accountable but see if you've never had
somebody tell you the truth like ma'am
what like your mindset your attitude
what's your the way you're moving like
like I'm sorry like and and actually
there's so much pride and ego in women
today because we've been pandered to and
told everybody's a queen everybody's a
princess you know everybody is you know
just because you're born with uh female
anatomy then that means that you should
be treated a certain way but every day
we see in the news there are women who
are not fit to even walk the earth that
what they've done to their children what
they've done to other people there's
just a scandal that came out I won't say
the word but this woman falsely accused
several young men of doing something to
her these young men try to delete
themselves because it was absolutely lie
now evidence came out recently where she
went to the store bought a hammer beat
herself oh my goodness oh my gosh
if it wasn't for other men coming around
and supporting these young men and they
were these these older men were canceled
for because they were trying to
um support men who did essay and just
because she was a woman she was believed
and I'm not saying that doesn't happen
happen to my mother that's how I have an
older my older sister came from that
when she was 14. so of course I actually
come from a family that's happened but I
still know several stories of women who
have falsely accused ruined these young
men's lives and guess what you know what
society says after that
that young woman she this is one woman
who was finally held accountable because
of her lies and destroying their life
but do you know what happened those
young men most of them who have been
falsely accused they lose their
scholarship they use their jobs they
lose everything and then there's nothing
to say if it goes away and it wasn't
true you never hear accountability you
never hear any woman go to jail
there needs to be a law for it who do
you think as many of many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible